We're going to modify this rank algorithm that we had before to do what I suggested.
It's going to return a kind of slightly sorted or less than the one that was given
with regard to some value of v.
There is a lot of ways to do this some are cleaner and more efficient that others.
I'm going to do the way I'm doing it just to be simple.
This is a very simple idea all we're going to do is we're going to keep track of a list of values
that are known to be smaller than v that are in L and the ones that are bigger than v.
We're going to loop through all the values.
Anytime we encounter one that's smaller than v, we put it in the smaller list.
Every time we find one that's bigger than v, we put it in the bigger list
and then we glue them altogether.
First the smaller then v and the bigger. Now, this sort of plus equals a list construct.
It's not immediately obvious what the running time of this is in Python.
In fact, I think its probably not constant time, but you can create a version
where each of these steps is constant time so that this entire routine runs in θn
because all we're doing is we're touching each of the values in the list to construct a new list
Let's run this and see what it does. All right. It seems to be done.
Here is 84, and you'll notice that these are all the elements of the original list.
84 is here. Everything to the right of it is bigger than 84.
Everything to the left of it is smaller than 84. So we partition the list around 84.